il est temps maintenant de remettre le
prix de la meilleure musique car
qu'est-ce que rec est ce que serait une
série sans une bonne musique et ben ce
serait d'eric et pour remettre ce prix
je vais accueillir non pas un rom et en
met 4 c'est un groupe de musique que
j'adore énormément ils m'ont fait une
grande impression quand je les ai vus la
première fois sur scène en plus leurs
vidéos leurs vidéos font des millions de
vues sur internet
ils sont là ce soir pour une mission
très spéciale je vous demande un
tonnerre d'applaudissements pour
accueillir berry wam
le maire
les
les gars savent votre mission
on est très alors c'est parti à chambéry
web votre mission si vous l'acceptez est
de remettre le prix de la meilleure
musique pour ce faire vous devrez
interpréter un maximum de musique de
séries pendant 3 minutes 30 et ce sans
aucun instrument a marre vous même ce
message de cuba dans 3 2
[Musique]
je
je leur fais les heures suivantes a
pleuré avec moi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
oui
gorki
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce
je
à qui
mission accomplie
[Applaudissements]
bravo les gars déchire
est-ce que vous êtes prêts pour votre
seconde mission vers guam on est prêt
seconde mission de la meilleure vue de
série est attribué à
c'est insoutenable happiness sixième
victoire l'équipe est au tapis de souris
sont déjà été récompensé pour le
meilleur scénario ce que de polémiques
une embrouille qu'est ce que sont bien
les séries nordique ces dernières années
au rapport
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
malheureusement je ne suis pas le
compositeur mais j'accepte ce prix au
nom de inge king and big n des plus
grands compositeurs norvège j'ai eu le
plaisir de travailler avec lui chose à
plusieurs reprises
xstrata 6 est fabuleux merci beaucoup je
suis très heureuse lui d'avoir reçu ce
prix
c'est un immense plaisir c'est une
grande surprise
tous mes remerciements et bon au jury
c'est magnifique de recevoir ce prix
[Applaudissements]